some were highly anticipated some looked
intriguing on the surface but failed to
deliver and some struggled to even make
the public aware of their existence but
they all have one thing in common they
tanked badly at the box office
solo a Star Wars story opened in May to
a shrug from audiences and its
underwhelming box office left at the
first thumb in the Star Wars franchise
to be branded a bonafide flop the red
flag seemed obvious in retrospect from
original directors Phil Lord and Chris
Miller departing late in production to
incoming director Ron Howard reshooting
three-quarters of the movie it seemed as
if everything that could go wrong dead
well done with Glover provided a bright
spot at the young lando calrissian solo
felt unnecessary star wars fatigue may
also have been a factor in the film's
failure and the decision to open the
film while Avengers infinity war was
still in theaters may have played a part
as well somewhat ironically it wasn't
just one thing that sunk so low Dwayne
the rock Johnson starring in your
picture is usually a pretty safe
indication of box-office success that is
gotta go to work
unfortunately 2018 skyscraper left
audiences supremely uninterested perhaps
due to the fact that the film leaned a
little too heavily into it's throwback
action movie roots even critics who were
entertained found it to be incredibly
derivative with a one hundred twenty
five million dollar budget and an
expensive advertising campaign to match
skyscraper would have had to do
gangbusters overseas to avoid losing
money and it didn't quite manage it
whether crowds were turned off by the
familiar story or experiencing a bit of
a rock fatigue skyscraper turned out to
be a whiff for the magnetic star the
John Travolta biopic Gotti got a lot of
press due to its star and subject
infamous mob boss John Gotti leading up
to its screening at can but its
reception at the festival was less than
rapturous and upon its June release in
the u.s. few critics even bothered to
review it literally every single one
that did huffily Pam the film every
aspect of the film's production was
blasted from its lack of coherent themes
and ham-fisted direction to Travolta's
distractingly terrible lead performance
the movie failed to even make back half
of its paltry 10 million dollar budget
and those involved in its production
only need to watch the film to see why
gaudy flops so hard
alpha tells the story of a prehistoric
youth who becomes separated from his
hunting group and partners up with a
lone wolf in order to survive it's a
thrilling gorgeously shot adventure but
while the film's bored with critics it
failed to connect with audiences with an
advertising campaign which seemed to be
aimed more squarely at dog lovers and
fans of epic adventure alpha simply
didn't generate the kind of positive
word-of-mouth that it needed it also had
the misfortune of squaring off against
crazy rich Asians and the mag to
surprising hits that cleaned up at the
box office
alpha failed to make back its budget
domestically but it seems destined for a
robust second life on home video after
years of development Brian Henson the
son of legendary Muppets creator Jim
Henson finally got to bring his passion
project the happy time murders for
theatres unfortunately said passion
project was the opposite of everything
his father stood for the vulgar puppet
based comedy was far too raunchy for
fans of Henson's work and executed too
poorly to engage audiences who showed up
expecting all the raunch
the film constituted a gigantic wave for
talented star Melissa McCarthy and an
inauspicious non muppet feature debut
for Henson the film barely need back
half of its budget domestically in the
wake of withering critiques and toxic
word of mouth its biggest crime though
[Applause]
all year long fans were pumped beyond
belief for the predator a fresh new
entry in the series originated by the
1987 Arnold Schwarzenegger classic
predator it had a unique spin on the
story template a great cast including
keegan-michael key Thomas Jane and
Olivia Munn and the sure directorial
hand of Shane black who as an actor
appeared in the original film all the
pieces were in place but a funny thing
happened on the way to the multiplex
they forgot to assemble those pieces
into a watchable movie black and company
seem to have overestimated the public
appetite for the sequel beyond the
originals fanbase in the film itself
simply failed to deliver for those that
did see it aside from being an
adaptation of a beloved novel a wrinkle
in time encouraged high expectations
with a stellar cast and obvious
commitment to diversity it was the first
big-budget tentpole film to be directed
by a black woman ava duvernay and the
cast included Mindy Kaling Reese
Witherspoon and Oprah Winfrey
unfortunately audiences simply failed to
materialize and perhaps due to lukewarm
critical response the usual young adult
crowd declined to turnout as well
the film's convoluted marketing
certainly didn't help matters confusing
audiences unfamiliar with the source
materials complicated by overall a
wrinkle in time took in just over one
hundred million dollars domestically and
it didn't fare much better overseas
action points had an absolutely golden
premise based on a notoriously dangerous
real-life New Jersey theme park the film
star Johnny Knoxville of jackass fame as
the irresponsible owner of action point
featuring plenty of actual stunts from
its seasoned performers the film
promised lowbrow belly laughs along the
lines of the Jackass film series however
fans found the theme park narrative to
be awkwardly grafted onto what seemed
like another jackass movie worse even
though Knoxville practically killed
himself making the movie the stunts were
seen as uninspired and the laughs were
few and far between action points poor
execution was its doom action points
struggled to make back even a quarter of
its budget leading to the very real
possibility that we've seen johnny
Knoxville grievously injured himself for
our amusement for the last time despite
not being a sequel reboot or adaptation
the hurricane heist looked like
guaranteed dollar signs due to its high
concept and directorial pedigree
director Rob Cohen gave us the original
fast in the
and xxx both high-octane stunts heavy
films which bloomed into surprisingly
profitable franchises the plot follows a
band of thieves who try to rob the u.s.
men during a category 5 storm and the
film appeared to be a welcomed throwback
to the intense diehard esque thrillers
of yesteryear unfortunately the
hurricane heist threw back just a bit
too hard
well this hurricane can change people
from a lot today so we got to go yes
even before brother review skewered the
movie for being ridiculously derivative
full of plot holes and poorly shot
audiences stayed away in droves the
movie failed to break 1 million dollars
on its opening day and finished its
theatrical run with the return of barely
6 million dollars on a budget six times
that Winchester appeared to have both
the premise and the pedigree to be a
potential horror classic Dame Helen
Mirren starred a Sarah Winchester a
woman who spent decades building
addition after addition on to her famous
mansion the real Sarah Winchester may
have been plagued by poor mental health
and too much time and money but
Winchester posited that she was driven
by something more supernatural writer
directors the spierig brothers delivered
a nifty sci-fi thriller in 2014's
predestination but their previous gig
had been his guns for hire on jigsaw
which was less well received with
Winchester they displayed a distinct
lack of interest in elevating the
material instead relying on cheap jump
scares and questionable plotting many
critics wondered how they were able to
coax the great Mirren into appearing in
the film Hotel Artemus is a futuristic
sci-fi thriller boasting a cast that any
first-time feature director would trade
a pinky for Jodie Foster sterling Kate
Brown Charlie Day Dave Bautista and Jeff
Goldblum to name a few the story
revolves around a secret hospital for
criminals in a dystopian future but
director drew Pierce's preference for
style over substance resulted in what
could have been a mind-blowing premise
falling curiously flat worse the film's
marketing did nothing to pull audiences
in despite working from his own
screenplay
Pierce managed to deliver a picture that
felt half-baked and aimless even its
kindest critics viewed it as little more
than pretty cool to look at which was
nowhere near enough to engage audiences
despite its modest 50 million dollar
budget hotel Artemus didn't even crack
half that at the domestic box office as
any good hotel owner will tell you you
just can't turn a profit with that kind
of vacancy rate
annihilation based on the acclaimed
novel of the same name is by most
accounts a very good film Natalie
Portman heads up an amazing cast
alongside Oscar Isaac and Tessa Thompson
the film's heavy premise and assured
direction by director Alex Garland won
over critics but audiences responded
with surprising indifference
I don't know where it was
what it was how is that possible movies
aimed at adults have struggled in recent
years and paramount may have exacerbated
this problem by striking a deal for
annihilations international rights with
Netflix before release the film dropped
on Netflix around the time of its
theatrical release and virtually every
market except North America and China
severely cutting into its overseas
profitability the film failed to make
back its 40 million dollar budget but
considering all the rave reviews
everyone who took a pass at the theater
will almost certainly catch it
eventually on Netflix
NBC's this is Us has become one of
network televisions breakout hits of the
last few years so it stood to reason
that the melodramatic family-oriented
formula could translate to success on
the big screen as well at least that was
Amazon Studios thinking they recruited
series creator Dan Fogelman to write and
direct life itself a similarly themed
feature with an all-star cast including
Olivia Wilde's Oscar Isaac and Antonio
Banderas
however mic itself struggled to a four
point 1 million dollar domestic gross
which can only partially be chalked up
to absolutely brutal reviews critics who
caught its debut at the Toronto
International Film Festival ripped it to
bits and audiences completely ignored
the film for his part filled them and
blamed its failure on critics who didn't
understand the film rather than take
responsibility for his almost comically
tragic over-the-top misfire medieval
epics are notoriously hit and miss and
the latest big-screen iteration of Robin
Hood was far more miss than hit critics
savaged the film for its forced edginess
winking anachronism and emphasis on
spectacle none of which would have
mattered if the film had hooked
audiences but they were a little busy
the weekend of its release flocking to
see Ralph breaks the internet and Cretu
to eagerly anticipated sequels when the
dust cleared Robin Hood failed to scrape
together even half of its budget
domestically the film's aggressive
marketing campaign probably didn't help
matters as it seems audiences simply
found no purpose in an overly edgy take
on a tale that Hollywood has been
telling for over a century
the 100 million dollar film is one of
the biggest money losers of the last
couple years
ironically it seems like Robin Hood
missed the mark
[Music]